just from an ideal standpoint I've
always been the type of person that
thinks you know people should be free to
do what they want as long as they're not
harming anyone else hi I'm Ted bellacor
with reason TV and today i'll be
speaking with David sands David doc
sands is a Doyle's room sponsored
professional poker player who's one more
online majors than anyone in the world
in addition to poker you're interested
in the free market world yeah how did
that happen um well I've always just I
grew up in a small town called Bozeman
Montana and there was a libertarian
organization they're called free
foundation for research on economics the
environment and I did an internship with
them for two and a half years while I
was in college and I was fortunate
enough to be able to work on them on
pelerin society and for those who don't
know the mont pelerin society is sort of
the be all and end all the free market
world that was started by FA Hayek in
the 40s exactly a mont pelerin you know
to me is just basically a celebration of
free market and libertarian ideals and
you know that the Salt Lake conference I
was able to help organize and attend you
know for years back was just a great
learning experience really got to hang
out with a lot of brilliant minds and
just kind of see you know quite a bit
about the about the libertarian world
and the ideals that those people are
fighting for and if I wasn't involved in
poker and if I didn't love poker so much
I really think I would still be working
or you know involved in in
libertarianism and promoting free market
more you know just just as a as a
daytime job because I really I really
think they do great stuff and what are
you drawn toward any kind of policy
areas or well I used to work when i
worked at free i dealt a lot with just
government taxation and just sort of
cutting unnecessary spending i used to
do here remember this is like five or
six years ago but i used to write papers
about you know portions of the montana
tax expenditure that was just wasted and
you know some of the you guys know
better than I do but some of the things
the government spends money on are just
absolutely laughable I know you guys
have a whole old sent out of pocket I
have a billion dollar at public school
right here damn straight
yeah so you know there's just there's
just countless ways the government can
waste money and I guess just from a just
from an ideal standpoint I've always
been the type of person that thinks you
know people should be free to do what
they want as long as they're not harming
anyone else and I guess I just from the
time that I was young when I was
formulating my you know kind of my
conceptions of who I was I just always
thought that government policy just in
general more often than not trampled and
impeded people's ability to do what they
wanted rather than facilitated it do you
it seems like there there may be more of
a libertarian strain in the world of
Poker just by the nature of the game and
what it entails is that true do you see
that among the people you play with well
I think that might be increasingly true
just because of what the government's
trying to do to outlaw online poker in
the United States and you know all of
the hoops that they're making us online
players that live in the United States
do just to just to be able to play the
game we love on the Internet I think
there's some element just in terms of
the type of people of the game of tracks
but I think more than that just in
recent years the last three years the
government has really made it difficult
for us players to play online at the
same time that they're facilitating
lotteries they're telling us that poker
is a game of chance that we shouldn't be
allowed to play and so I think I think
it's just kind of silly for those of us
to understand the game and you know know
without a doubt that it's a game of
skill because it's what we do for a
living and we do it every day and we see
the people that aren't skilled lose
money over and over you in the long run
we see the people that are skilled you
know final table big events and win big
tournaments consistently can you address
the issue of the the controversy of over
how pokers should be regulated hinges to
a large degree on whether it's a game of
chance or skill yeah can you talk about
why that's such a big question well I
guess from a policy standpoint it's a
big question because there's a I guess
there's a tradition to some extent in US
law or US policy and the government
banning games of chance and and you know
supporting or at least enabling people
to engage
games of skill and so there have been
multiple Supreme Court rulings that him
you know the Supreme Court tries to
state whether poker is a game of locker
game of skill so anyone who actually
knows the game there's just I mean
they're just as know there's there's
really no argument boger like I said at
the outset is a completely math based
game if you give me two cards and you
give yourself two cards you know I can
tell you in less than a second what the
chance is what the percentage chance
that I'm going to win the hand is and
what the percentage chance that you're
gonna win the end is and probably the
one of the biggest ways they want to
restrict your ability to do that is and
it's the 2006 law it's one of those
ridiculously titled laws and I'm gonna
have to look at the unlawful internet
gambling enforcement act or hui jia hao
to explain what that did in my opinion
what it did the government wrote an
unenforceable law which said that people
that have IP addresses the United States
can't play online poker and since they
probably knew when they wrote it that it
wasn't gonna be possible to enforce they
just decided to like they always do or
likely frequently do pass the
responsibility for the enforcement on to
private corporations which in this case
is banks so what the US government for
my understanding did with respect to the
law is they didn't actually make the act
of playing online poker illegal they
made helping poker players that have us
IP addresses get money on or off of an
online poker site illegal and a silver
line a Liberty possible libertarian
silver lining and all this is now with
the government spending that at record
levels other nations primarily in Europe
are now warming up to two online poker
because surprise they get tax revenue
exactly yeah there's a ton of tax
revenue from online poker and you know I
think it looks like in recent months the
US government has been a little more
open to the idea of regulating and
taxing it just because I think they've
finally started to realize the
tremendous amount of money that has and
will continue to go offshore if they
don't you know but for me from a policy
standpoint it's kind of analogous to
medical marijuana you know people are
going to smoke anyway people are going
to play
boger online anyway and you know the US
government especially the state of
California is in a tremendous amount of
debt and you know why not why not
capitalizing the opportunity to get free
money from a activity that Americans are
already engaging in the former senator
from New York al D'Amato is now engaged
in some honest work he's the chairman of
the poker players Alliance and this is
one thing that he had to say and an
article not too long ago quote under the
liberty and freedom section of the new
GOP website America speaking out more
americans voted to legalize internet
poker than weighed in on any other issue
that should come as no surprise when
president-elect Barack Obama solicited
ideas on his new website change gov
legalizing internet poker was one of the
top two issues voters want this and
politicians are always you know
pretending to want to do what the voters
want so what's the problem why why isn't
this getting more traction well that's a
really good question and I definitely
think that the overwhelming amount of
voters and just people in the United
States whether they're educated on the
issue or not do support the legalization
of online poker because you know they
have to recognize that even if they're
not going to play online poker
themselves it's a great additional form
of revenue for the government and you
know why not if if they're opposing it
one of the government tax it and
regulated it was similar with when they
had what was the YouTube debate and the
top question was you know why don't you
legalize marijuana or something to do
with marijuana and Obama just sort of
you know chocolate although they're
there because the stoners again yeah
exactly well I mean you know sometimes
you gotta you gotta really fight to get
your voice heard and you know it's it's
clear that the online poker is one of
those issues that it's just despite the
fact that the voters wants by the fact
that logic and you know financial
reasoning economics dictates that it
makes sense it's just it's a tough issue
so the PPA is doing a lot of great work
and I think I do think that there you
know there's some bright sides i think
that the US government is finally
starting to open its eyes and recognize
how much money there is potentially to
be made and you know unfortunately it
seems to come down to that more often
than not even if the vote
just want it you know the policies
aren't going to get changed until it's
obvious that the government is going to
benefit from monetary perspective but
hopefully they've gotten to that point
the government and you know recognize
that that the money is there and that
the regulation needs to happen